jetzt kommen zu einem fall der wirklich
zu absurd klingt um wahr zu sein knapp
900 euro sollen bei einem jungen mann
aus hamburg von seiner kleinen
sozialhilfe gepfändet werden und das
ohne wirklichen grund es geht um passen
sie auf gez schulden
es ist kaum zu fassen eigentlich ist
merlin von der gez befreit der 23
jährige arbeitet in einer
behindertenwerkstatt verpackt
ersatzteile für seine arbeit bekommt er
nur ein taschengeld
280 euro das sozialamt gibt ihm noch
rund 300 euro dazu und genau weil er
sozialhilfe bezieht ist er vom
rundfunkbeitrag befreit eigentlich doch
dann flattert ein brief der gez ins haus
berlin soll gebühren der letzten vier
jahre bezahlen
877 euro nur bei der forderung bleibt es
nicht das geld wird direkt gespendet von
seiner mini sozialhilfe einbehalten bild
fragt geht es noch
ja und genau über diesen kuriosen fall
wollen wir jetzt mit unserem kollegen
frank ochse sprechen frank schön dass du
da bist unglaubliche geschichte was war
da los alisa wir sind auch in der
redaktion total fassungslos mal wieder
die gez die hat natürlich jetzt beitrag
service aber wir sagen weiterhin gez da
haben wir wirklich sehr viele beschwert
und wie kann es wirklich sein dass man
einen behinderten auch noch dieses
taschengeld findet man muss dazu sagen
dieser beitrag service die fänden sofort
da gibt es halt auch gar keine
ankündigungsschreiben und es ist
wirklich unfassbar wer hat da versagt
also und es ist unglaublich was diese
jungen wirklich passiert ist ja das ist
schon eine ziemliche frechheit muss man
sagen wir wollen mal mit den betroffenen
selber sprechen und zwar mit merlin und
seinem vater herrn brandt
berlin herbrand wie schlimm ist diese
situation jetzt für sie persönlich
ja also sehr schlimm weil die
bekanntheit nur so wenig
und das ist eigentlich so viel
lebensmittel halt ein bisschen und halt
auch seine hobbys
und dass ihm das einfach so weg genommen
wird finde ich eine frechheit weil wir
hatten bis jetzt immer alle schreiben
hingeschickt nennt die befreiung
schreiben und es heißt ja immer uns wir
sind angekommen seine nicht und das kann
ich nicht verstehen weil wir das alles
in einem briefumschlag packen
und dann haben sie ihm das konto
befindet und es wurde gesagt wenn wir
alles nachreichen nochmal beantragen
beim arbeitsamt um beim sozialamt denn
welt uns das zurück überwiesen und wir
haben alles beantragt und zurücknehmen
nachgereicht und es wurde bis jetzt
nichts zurück überwiesen nicht mal ein
schreiben gekommen oder so außer dass er
jetzt befreit ist bis 22 jetzt bis
nichts bis zum siebten monat der brand
sie haben also selber schon einiges
unternommen waren da hinterher haben
sich gekümmert was hoffen sie jetzt
genau was passiert
ja ich hoffe ja dass das die wichtigen
verantwortlichen hören und sehen und
dass die sich dann meinen kopf drum
machen dass man den behinderten menschen
der sich jeden tag der geht acht stunden
am tag arbeiten und 40 stunden die woche
er ist immer fleißig und kriegt ein
taschengeld und dass sie ihm das dann
auch noch wegnehmen das finde ich
einfach ja dass es geht nicht immer ein
herz
berlin vielleicht auch noch eine frage
mal direkt an dich wie fassungslos warst
du was hast du gedacht als du plötzlich
diesen brief bekommen hast dass du all
dieses geld bezahlen muss
ja ich finde es also nur blöd von denen
dass sie mich - weg in dem moment nicht
wegnehmen
das können wir auf jeden fall sehr gut
verstehen und deshalb waren wir auch
nicht tatenlos hierbei bild fragen ich
glaube du hast jetzt gute nachrichten
oder ja also wir konnten es wirklich
nicht fassen und wir haben den
beitragssatz die gez da wirklich
malträtiert und am ende können wir ihnen
sagen die forderungen sind aus der welt
es geht um die fast 900 euro und auch
die noch anstehende veränderungen geben
alle vom tisch weg was sagen sie
so schön sein könnte berlin super keine
sonst kriegt die gtz hat es endlich
kapiert dass wir das ist ein beitrag
mehr bezahlen
was man das freut mich für ihn und unter
heute ist auch
die gez hat uns auch noch mal gesagt das
tut ihm wirklich wahnsinnig leid und sie
sind dankbar dafür dass wir die gez
darauf aufmerksam gemacht haben und ihr
stehen da zwei glückliche menschen das
macht es natürlich auch sehr froh
herzlichen dank
herzlichen dank ich glaube eben großes
zelt wird jetzt vielleicht noch ein
bisschen gefeiert wir schauen in zwei
sehr sehr glückliche gesichter und wir
sind wirklich froh dass wir da helfen
konnten dass unsere spar fox redaktion
sich da so reingehängt hat für sie beide
ich glaube das ist ein guter tag oder
danke schön dass jetzt nicht dank
nochmal von uns
bestimmt die tränen die augen tränen ich
weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll
super super da geht ein gedanke vielen
dank brandt schön dass wir helfen
konnten herzlichen dank auch an dich
dass ihr euch ein gesetzt habt ja und
wenn sie auch ein anliegen haben im bild
kämpft für sie wenn sie hilfe gebrauchen
könnten unsere kollegen sind für sie da
schreiben sie uns gerne ihren fall per e
mail an bild - kämpft at bild de und
dann setzt sich frank opfer mit seinem
team auch für sie ein